this is the human center autonomous
vehicle one of the main ideas underlying
our work is that solving the task of
autonomous driving is more complicated
and more fascinating than the strictly
robotics challenges of localization
mapping perception control and planning
you also have to enable the vehicle to
perceive predict communicate and
collaborate with human beings
the humans inside the car like the
driver and the passengers and the humans
outside the car like the pedestrians
cyclists the drivers of other vehicles
and even tell the operators the studies
the code the data and the demos we
release all consider autonomous driving
in this kind of human centered way where
the control is transferred from human to
machine back to human based on the state
of the external driving environment and
the state of the driver what we'd like
to demonstrate today is the basics
voice-based transfer of control from
human to machine based on whether the
driver is paying attention to the road
or not inside we have two cameras on the
driver one on the driver's face one on
the driver's body with two cameras
looking at the external roadway and we
have a few other cameras for filming
purposes there's a center stack display
showing who's in control of the vehicle
human or machine so currently the human
is in control of the vehicle let's drive
let's split the car and drive on the
center stack display it shows the gear
as drive
the perception control and driver states
sensing algorithms you see today I'm
running in real-time but the
visualizations you're seeing in video
are done in offline post-processing our
perception system today is vision based
using two neural networks one is doing
road segmentation the other is doing
object detection of vehicles cyclists
pedestrians traffic science traffic
lights the acceleration braking and
steering of the car is performed by PID
controllers the driver states sensing
that we're showing today is glance
region classification and that's
performed using 3d convolutional neural
networks high-level planning decisions
to transfer control or to stop the
vehicle are performed by a decision
fusion algorithm that combines risk
factors in the external environment and
driver state whether the drivers paying
attention to the road or not safety for
us is the number one priority always we
are on a test track the vehicles and
pedestrians here today are all part of
our team all part of the demonstration
there's another safety driver in the car
that can stop the vehicle at any moment
by pressing a single button ok
let's engage any distracting activity
Twitter and let's send a tweet
I'm typing
this tweet
while driving in the MIT semi autonomous
vehicle
on
a test track
Lex you appear distracted would you like
me to take over yes please
great I am taking control of steering
and braking the car is now in control as
the center stack display shows so I will
continue with the tweet the car knows
that I am NOT
paying attention
[Music]
and has taken control after asking me
nicely for it
[Music]
video out tomorrow okay here goes
nothing it's posted very well might be
the first tweet ever sent from an
autonomous vehicle while it's driving
itself
[Music]
elevated driving risk detected I am
stopping for a pedestrian Lex pedestrian
is blocking our lane of travel should i
honk
no please shift gear to park great we
are now in park
that was a demo of the basics perception
motion planning driver state sensing
transfer control and tweeting and we
have a lot more to explore together our
team is working on various aspects of
human and artificial intelligence toward
our mission to save lives through
effective human robot collaboration
you